very curious for me on this particular
bill because we're not spending any
money
I don't know why we ended up with this
one but hey good as any post does
anybody have any comment to make on this
starting out in a good good way here
well I would entertain entertain a
motion to uh for ought to pass
Mary okay
second
what what's the distance oh
the gist of the bill is moving the
amount that a school board can accept
without a special meeting to twenty
thousand dollars from five thousand
Yeah by all means
I uh oh good morning I misunderstood a
question I thought you were asking the
public if they uh had any comments I'm
new this is for the board um I I would
just like to share the thought that uh I
was actually talking to representative
hack and Phillips about it during the
public hearing that
it is good to keep up with inflation if
this build you know if this uh amount
was decided you know 18 years ago
obviously inflation happens but we
looked up and uh you know the equivalent
of five thousand dollars about 18 years
ago in today's money would be about 7
500. so I would like to express concern
over the fact that the raised to 25 20
000 is significantly higher than
inflation and it actually kind of
changes the threshold in a very material
way I was wondering if maybe as a
committee we should consider keeping it
closer to inflation
amounts and I again
it's
uh I heard it
I heard it more as a a facilitation of
donation rather than some kind of
coupling of amounts of money that's how
thank you Mr chair yeah I think also to
take into consideration is how things
have gotten more expensive regardless of
inflation and also that this is an
opportunity so certain schools are going
to be raising fairly significant amounts
of funds which they're just turning over
to the school and I don't think it's
unusual for them to raise more than the
7 500 that representative papovichi is
suggesting in terms of just inflation so
my point is that there are factors
beyond inflation just in terms of how
much things are costing and how some
school systems are pretty darn good at
raising funds that they turn over to the
school and I see this as an
administrative way of making it easier
for the schools to accept that money
without having to go through a more uh
not necessarily rigorous but I forget
the word I want a demanding or onerous
foreign
school board for nine years and and I'm
On The Board of Trustees and a lot of
times these this amount gets in the way
you know the five thousand I mean if
somebody wants to give a donation to say
start a uh a scholarship fund it uh it
tends to be very cumbersome because you
have to have a public hearing for the
school board to you know if it's for the
school to to uh you know accept that
money and of course it's appropriated by
them so I think this is a reasonable
amount uh you know it's it's not it's
it's going to be reviewed by the school
board
when they accept the money within the
school board meeting so I think this uh
this is a good idea thank you
any other comment
well if the clerk would
thank you Mr chair and are you gonna
vote first or last
I'll vote last thank you then um
let me get my sheet please yep
so uh Joseph representative by Peter
representative Bean
uh myself yes representative Buco yes
representative Heath yes
representative Murray yes representative
hacken Phillips yes and representative
chairman emmeric yes
thank you well it's obviously unanimous
okay
eight well we have a few minutes so
oh
being 10 15 Apple time we will start
discussions on House Bill 468
which is an appropriate appropriation
for an attorney to rewrite the
Department of Education manual
comments from the committee
go ahead
you got to fire up thank you thank you
Mr chairman I thought of a question that
I didn't think of yesterday at the
hearing
but what you're talking about here is
I'm actually amending at the education
law
so what are the what's how what's the
mechanics of doing that I mean this one
attorney is not going to change the laws
it's going to have to go through the
whole process and House and Senate and
right
well whoever wants to respond to it I
don't know yesterday during the hearing
yesterday that's what it sounded like
you're going to hire this attorney for a
thank you uh it's good to be back in
this room where I sat in that chair more
than a few years ago uh when this when
this division also had taxation when
there was no Ways and Means Committee
and uh I remember the night Claremont 2
came down and realized my life's about
to change and it did and it sure did
uh I wanted to talk I'll talk to you
about the process of recodification not
that we have done it uh significantly in
OLS uh but that does fall in our
bailiwick and Mickey has uh has uh some
background information that I have
prepared for the division
uh
and uh
recodification in my business with
talking with other legislative service
directors yes we call ourselves the lsds
uh it's it's a it's appropriate uh when
talking to my counterparts around the
country recodification is a real dirty
word because it can be uh it can be a
disaster
it takes it's monumental
uh I am not speaking against this I
think it needs to be done as well as in
a lot of other agencies and that we've
heard Rumblings
from other agencies seeking
recodification of their statutes and
recodification really is a cleanup uh
a little bit of history in the first 150
years of the state we were recodifying
all our state laws the entire entirety
of the state laws about every 15 years
we haven't done it since 1955 but in
1950 when we created the RSI rsas the
revised statutes annotated uh but at
that time we only had about five volumes
of laws total in 1947 we had two volumes
I have them in my office on my bookshelf
if you want to take a look at that
sometime we now have 35 of these books
these two are the education statutes
most this one is includes libraries
where the where I have the the
piece of paper there
the education statutes are over 1500
pages
the bill that would result from
recodification will be at least 1500
pages so it's like nothing you have ever
seen
again it's not I'm not speaking against
this I think it needs to be done
but it's it's monumental
I have included in the packet uh
something from 1967 when the criminal
code was uh was recodified
and uh it took about six years to
produce a recodification bill of the
criminal code consisting of 44 pages
and that was a re and that required an
appropriation of twenty thousand dollars
in nineteen sixty seven dollars
for 44 pages
I have included here also and as the top
page shows you my my responsibilities in
uh chapter 17A and that does include
codification of that we don't actively
do that because we don't have the staff
but for instance we have a very large
bill on oplc right now it's a 75 page
bill for representative McGuire it's
somewhat of a recodification uh not
entirely the entirety of those statutes
but it was a major undertaking for us to
do here during the filing period uh and
that's you'll be seeing that coming out
shortly uh I also include
in the Virginia code Commission Virginia
has a very nicely laid out commission
defined with the authority to do to
undertake uh recodification
and uh so I include that there again uh
and they can do that with their staff
they have a lot more staff than than I
do here here downstairs at the State
House I also include at the end uh
and I'll tell this story a little bit
that in Colorado
uh they were recodifying their oplc
statutes
and
had buy-in from everyone and everyone
they had everyone involved the
practitioners the Attorney General's
office uh members of the bar association
the associations governed by by their
their oplc statutes uh numerous people
buy in the the office of their office of
legislative Services it's called the LLS
uh was the were the people that were
carrying out what the commission
requested again they have a much bigger
staff than than we do here
that took several years it was 1700 page
Bill
uh and uh and it required about 40 other
bills because
undoubtedly in these education statutes
there are things that should belong
somewhere else so when you take those
things out and you they have to go
somewhere else and so that means a
separate bill needs to be created and so
then Colorado that happened it uh and
just as an interesting note uh when it
came to the floor of the house there was
some uh things were moving too fast for
a certain certain group and uh
the the uh the next bill up after that
1700 page Bill uh was controversial so
there was a motion when that bill was on
the floor that the bill be read at
length meaning 1700 pages had to be read
read by the clerk uh which is what in
fact happened after some of the
shenanigans but uh so it was used as a
bit of a football
my bottom line is we need to have a Pros
start if we're going to do this we need
to have a process so that we can
replicate it for other agencies and
departments moving forward it needs to
be clear it needs to be comprehensive
because anything less really will create
disaster and I've heard it from other
States including Delaware in their
recodification of the criminal code
which was undertaken by the uh Supreme
Court
and they they have the the Chief Justice
hired a
a law professor from an Ivy League
School here in New England and uh let's
just say it was
it was a disaster because even the
go ahead question Dan thank you
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my questions
um just a couple of really quick
questions
would it be fair to say that you know
what is your opinion on the possibility
of this recodification happened in the
terms proposed by this bill in two years
and for a budget of a hundred thousand
I I really don't know I don't think that
it can be done in necessarily two years
from what for my discussions with other
states on major pieces of legislation uh
as far as the additional dollars I don't
know because most most States uh that
I've spoken to have large enough staffs
that where the commission is telling
them what to do looks through and says
okay these are not just renumber in this
fashion and then uh the staff can carry
a friend of mine is my counterpart in
California and we like to joke you know
I've got I've got uh seven drafting
attorneys he has 175. uh you know that's
so and so it's it's like the the mutton
Jeff in one corner in the opposite
corners of the country and we we uh we
kind of entertain others when we get
together at conferences because of the
differences between our two states but
uh it just need
can it be done externally using
additional help yes is it done that way
by the states yes but there needs to be
a strong
Commission on oversight steering
committee that that is there to uh to
steer the direction thank you and if I a
quick follow-up because that was my
second question
how would you suggest in your
professional experience that's the best
way to go about achieving this goal
because I think you know the goal is
definitely something we need to achieve
but I'm really concerned that this won't
do it and you know how would we best
proceed
I'm more than willing to sit down with
the department and others but I think
there needs to be uh there needs to be
certainly the department at the table
that need to be uh whether it be school
boards Association or others that that
use the laws education laws on a regular
basis there needs to be someone from the
Attorney General's office which was
noted yesterday I was had the hearing on
in the in the background in my office uh
there needs to be practitioners uh
lawyers that that work with in education
uh
there needs there needs to be a group
like as well as house members and
Senators because that that's uh they're
the ones that will likely say identify
what is substantive or not because you
don't that has to be clearly laid out
and in the Colorado bill that authorized
that commission it talks about what the
commission can do and you don't want to
have substantive changes you don't want
to make those those major changes in in
a recodification because that is a
recipe for failure also so you want to
keep it really to renumbering clean up
uh get rid of things that are
duplicative and uh
renumberings don't get rid of the
conflicts don't rewrite the law just fix
it correct okay correct thank you Mary
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um I used to work at the department of
Ed and it
that was 2009 when I left and it was
confusing then and federal laws have
come federal laws have gone we've
adjusted educational laws to meet the
needs of those requirements there's some
urgency to this I think I can't imagine
what it must be like for the attorneys
that have
I have to work with all of these laws
would perhaps
um instead of the law as written we
Define this as a commission
and we fund it
um and specify
a timeline or what we're looking for so
it wouldn't differ particularly from
what is here but it would spell a kind
of a process and it would fund what
needs to happen and I don't know if the
department thinks that's a good idea or
um
you need to start moving in destruction
if it's a physician in the analysis
definitely
without some other steps that we need to
involve
if we agree so as I testified yesterday
I don't know what the appropriate answer
so I've never done this but what we have
right now is not working for the
department and for the field of
medication that we need to start in the
direction of improving whatever that
ends up being completely versatile so
thank you thank you
yeah my my thought is this is another
one of those ones with we're looking at
the elephant here you know and and what
we've got is an ant uh so uh just for
the committee's benefit I I discusses
with Mary all of these bills that have
money in them it would be my intention
state to retain them because we don't
know what money we have to spend
uh so my inclination on this one is to
retain it and rewrite it
to be something bigger because if we got
to have a big idea we have to have a
bigger bill
uh this is a good start
but I think what you've highlighted
would be a better approach to say let's
organize how we're going to do this
before we start doing it yes uh and I
think that's what this bill could morph
into was is The Game Plan
of how to move forward and maybe some
funding or you know maybe for the next
fiscal year I don't know I'm just I'm
not trying to write the bill I'm just
saying I think if we need to work on
this
um this will give us two years if we
retain it but not really but I mean it
gives us a longer period of time
otherwise we have to take action on it
by crossover so that that would be my my
thoughts here Mary I just I think it's
it's really important though that that
we do put some money to it
um and we do need to rewrite it and it's
something that if we can plot out a
timeline I think that's really important
because just my experiences way back in
2009 I can't imagine all the bills that
have been passed since then and what
it's like now so I think there's some or
and if this must be across our our
government so um I think we have a big
job of habits well as as was stated I
think you said this could be a model of
how to do it for other other departments
this is Monumental any of you ever seen
a 1500 page bill before you know it's uh
it's certainly nothing that we have done
or any of my predecessors or
any our predecessors of being a former
legislator here uh has has done that
that one in 1967 criminal code big code
well important code clearly uh 44 Pages
uh I think agriculture was done not too
terribly long ago maybe 20 years uh but
certainly not the agricultural laws are
certainly not to the extent we have we
have here
yes
thank you Mr chair thank you for being
here I'd like your opinion uh you went
through uh Committee of all you know the
stakeholders who should be at the table
uh involved in this can I get your
opinion on
whether the stakeholders would be the
one who stakeholders who do the work or
if they're an advantage to having an
outside agency come in to do the work
and present to the committee
um and act to be to be frank I'm I would
lean towards an outside agency because
they don't have
um historical or background
knowledge which can be good but also
knowledge that gets in the way of what
you're trying to do that they're coming
in with just a clear lens without any
you know side issues and to have an
agency do the work which would take it
off of your backs but then have that
committee come in to say yes this is
what's working and this is what's not
working so uh can you tell me whether
you you think an outside agency is a
good idea or do you think it's this is
something that should be done totally
in-house in in your your group thank you
I
I guess I would I would say yes the the
answer is an outside agency or most
everywhere else it is would be the
department of my office legislative
Services would be the one to handle a
lot of this but as I've said we've I've
got seven attorneys and we're just
recovering from uh drafting all this
stuff right now and now we're in
amendments and uh you know people think
that a lot of members think that we
don't once we get through uh this
session that we have Summers off it
takes us a good month as after the
adjournment to get the bills enrolled
and sent up to the governor so uh
there's there's a month of work there
that everyone's working on we do the
publishing we're in charge of this book
getting these books and working with
Thompson Reuters West and getting the
laws of and getting the education
volumes out and the Fish and Game
volumes out and and other books that we
produce and we just got questions
yesterday from the publisher what about
all these contingencies that uh we have
been included in the laws over the past
year should we take them out and so we
we have a lot of things that we do uh
that that kind of behind the scenes and
this is certainly one of them I'm
getting kind of inside baseball-ish on
on inside legislative work but uh
yeah but they need that would be need to
be an appropriation to hire someone or
to hire a a group I don't know uh
that's something that would have that
needs to be considered but in my mind
the most important thing is getting
the uh
that commission or working group
steering committee with the stakeholders
uh set and the mission statement very
clear
thank you thank you thank you
um when I worked
at the department of Ed
I don't think a day went by when I
didn't have at least five conversations
with the Attorney General's office and
it is a matter of intent with our
legislation so I don't argue with that I
think it would be a good idea to have
somebody come in and do the work but I
think somehow someway the practitioners
and the attorneys our attorney general's
office they've been engaged in this um I
just remember the number of lawsuits
that we've had just
setting a policy or just getting out a
memo of a superintendent's
I would have to make sure that I ran it
by the Attorney General's office before
we sent it out to school districts just
to make sure everything was as it should
be and we're not getting anything in
place that shouldn't be there we have to
be careful about those things and with
the laws now with the way they conflict
with each other at times it's got to be
extremely confusing but I just I I hope
that we figure out some kind of a
commissioner process but I think we need
to engage these stakeholders and the
people who have been working with some
of these
laws that that they need to have some
input into this too and representative
Heath uh from a practical point when you
were finishing up at doe I was I I
served for nine years in the Hudson
School Board eight of which is chair
Lynn Ober was my vice chair for all all
those years so Lynn and I go have a long
history we've known each other uh
interesting a long a long time and in
addition to being on the school board
the Hudson's School Board I served on
the board for the academy for Science
and design as well as the private
another private true private school so I
have I I the old the old big education
volumes we talked about I that thing was
dog-eared and had more Post-it notes
hanging out of it uh and highlighted
highlights in it because I use that as a
as a Bible and yeah it's not
that that didn't mean that I interpreted
things correctly or intent of the
thank you Mr chairman no no thank you
for being here and thank you for all the
work you do at OLS it's amazing what you
can do with seven people well we have
more than seven people but those guys
but I mean your main lines I appreciate
that thank you it's I'll let them know
that it's very encouraging especially
when you like you say you go to other
conferences and uh you get one of one of
our big questions you really make a
hundred dollars a year I mean that's
that's a big one but uh the question I
had would you add Sunset Provisions to
this process
well I I I we're talking about just
restating the laws that are that are
already in existence so I don't if he's
talking about a sunset of the
commission's work if you will uh it it
would be nice to have some sort of
deadline I guess but since we're going
into pretty much unknown territory and
knowing in 67 it took six years and in
Colorado it took I think something
similar to that five years six years for
that big uh Omnibus Bill
I I just don't know I know we do things
different here and we tend to be more
efficient here but uh its unknown
territory as to how much time it
actually would take I think it would be
a good thing to have some sort of date
in there can always change it if it's
uh in uh
roughly 2011. we we looked at this and
uh we I don't know where it came from
but we figured out it would take six
years to recodify the education law and
uh with uh representative Balboni and at
the time he was chairman of education
and uh it uh we we found it I mean it
was a huge task I mean more than we can
handle because we're only you know
you're only guaranteed
you know two years and uh if it takes
six years you you're not even going to
have con Continuum of uh people to work
on this project that's right and you
have to also recognize that every
especially in education every session
you're going to have changes to those
laws so as you're rewriting those laws
we're getting new laws put on the books
that have to be Clara put aside or or
implemented that you can't forget about
not to mention that as part of this
process you have to have
tables that refer back so what was you
know RSA 195 what XYZ now becomes
rsa1234a and then and so you have to
have that crosswalk of what law now what
it was and what it is now and uh that's
uh think about that sort of spreadsheet
that's uh that's one of the things we do
at OLS is every statute every every bill
that affects each statute
we have a we have a list it's uh and of
of Are We amending are we deleting are
we
doing whatever to that statute so that
we can look back to try to eliminate the
conflicts which come up every single
session uh as to which law should take
precedence uh because we change we
change there are times we change the
same chapter of law the same section of
law five times in a legislative session
so that so we create we create those
sort of Master tables uh and that's a
significant undertaking each legislative
session but that's the sort of thing
that would have to happen with a with a
recodification as well
well
this is obviously grown to a bigger idea
and before we end on this discussion we
we have to have a next step on who's
going to do it
uh so I don't know is the prime sponsor
are you in the mood to
what stakeholders and all of that but
but that's minor I mean that's but
certainly uh you know I'm happy to work
with uh
I don't know whether it would be
I don't know who's going to be that well
I certainly certainly certainly with OLS
Department
because the wheelbarrow you're going to
dump is going in his Department
so he if he has some input he won't be
and and we're available all the time too
so I'm not handing you the ball saying
go no through the line but no one has
the counter on the market on a good idea
I'm sorry you've got to come up to the
mic I forgot about this broadcast yeah
yeah
all right well
for the record then the prime sponsors
agreed to carry the ball and help with
some revision of this bill to be a
bigger idea uh and have more
uh substance and probably more money
I would guess but that's
okay
so I would need a motion to retain this
primary
well if the clerk would call the roller
please
so we have a motion to retain
um I'm gonna
representative Petra
yes
representative Bean
representative of each memory yes
representative buco
representative Heath yes
representative Murray yes representative
haken Phillips yes and chairman Emerick
yes motion passes eight to zero okay
so we'll close the work session on HP
468 and we'll now open the work session
and this is the bill that pertains to
feminine hygiene products
so does anybody anybody happy yes Mary
I'm
I believe in the standards I'm not
familiar with the new standards for the
Department of Ed but in former standards
usually in school districts
um things like toilet tissue paper
towels
um those kinds of soap those kinds of
things are just generally
um purchased as part of the the school
maintenance and the things that they
provide on a day-to-day basis and it
just seems like
to actually pull out one particular
thing and say that the state needs to
pay for it
I just think it's confusing and might we
end up with um
numerous bills all of a sudden coming
forward to us saying that the state
needs to pay for
paper towels that are being used
excessively or something so I just I had
a little bit of concern about it and it
appears that um the current bill in its
current form seems to be working
um you know we have the school boards
Association here so maybe they can
comment because I don't know I'm not out
and about and I'm not hearing people say
things about it so I'm that would be a
question that I would ask but I just I I
don't know why we would single this out
foreign yes
yes yeah I'd like to ask a further
question from you know either
representative Edwards or someone when
they have a chance why we need the thing
about school districts may take
appropriate action to preclude or
prevent vandalism
Etc
um wouldn't they do that anyway why do
we need to have a particular provision
to say yes you can do this when I would
expect given the nature of some of these
incidents they would have they would do
that anyway that just seems to be common
sense and standard so I don't know why
that needs to be specified in the bill
so I'd be glad for response to that
so uh thank you Mr chair uh and and to
uh representative Murray's uh question
uh the uh principal testified yesterday
for Auburn Village School saying that uh
she believes that the the law created
um
constraints and requirements around the
provision of these products
in a way in which it's costing them
incremental money and that it's creating
waste and
um so
um so so I I guess I would defer to her
um because she has an attorney that
helps them interpret the law and to
figure out what's required to implement
the law and and I and given that I know
her a bit I know that she wouldn't want
to you know over regulate herself to do
that so I I can only assume that she's
acting in a reasonable way based on the
school's attorney guidance and to
representative Heath if I may Well
I this bill did not intend to single out
a particular product it intended to
single out a particular legislative
action that was taken in a prior term to
add
this specific mandate with a total
disregard to the 28-a issue and and so
my frustration with with this issue for
years now is is that uh as legislatures
we tend to get we've been tending to get
distracted by the the product and the
and the need for the product and and
somehow it keeps us from thinking about
our 28a obligation and and this is
really me you know saying hey if we're
it it's it's bad practice I think uh for
us to start chipping away at this
constitutional prohibition of unfunded
mandates because if we get this
precedent and we get this Habit in place
then what's next we'll continue down the
road of adding unfunded mandates so so
your concern is in the other direction
that we'll start to fund things that
aren't mentioned in State Statute I'm
more concerned about adding things to
state state statute that are unfunded
mandates
thank you chairman I just want to State
you know in regards to the earlier
remarks about why are we singling this
out that
I think if the state creates obligations
out of other governments the
Constitution clearly says the state has
to pay for them if we don't like paying
for them we shouldn't mandate that I'm I
I'm fine with the law is written but
what is the lowest bust the state also
incurred that obligation to fund it fund
it properly and it is our constitutional
duty to do so so I do not have a concern
you know I do not share the concern
Express that this may lead to other
things that are not State mandates being
required to be funded by the state
because the basis for this very funding
is very simple it's an unfunded mandate
and we should fund it if some other
things are not a clear mandate for the
state we don't have an obligation to
fund it we may choose to fund them or
not but it would not bear the same type
of obligation that I perceive here thank
you
thank you Mr chair I think just
following along the lines of this you
know stream of thought if we're
concerned about an unfunded mandate
regarding to feminine products my
question would be
then are also the requirements to have
toilet paper and paper towel also
unfunded mandates and now we need to go
back and start thinking about you know
I don't I don't believe there's
legislation that says you have to have
toilet paper and paper towels I don't
know
what that big book maybe there is I'm
not sure
I just think it's a good question to
consider I mean these products are also
used in the restroom and considered
required to use the restroom so why are
we singling out this specific product
when we're also paying for toilet paper
and paper towel so I think if that's you
know the theory we're gonna go with we
need to be intellectually consistent
across the board well one of the one of
the conclusions is we can rescind the
legislation
and let the school districts do as they
might I mean that's that's an
alternative down the road for sure
do you want to make a comment uh only at
your invitation Mr chair it's your work
session uh I I would I would say that
the uh the to the representative's point
the the the theory here is is a simple
one those other products that happen to
be in the bathroom are not mandated by
state law if if you could find the
Mandate in state law on those being
required then I think your concern would
be validated uh as it turns out this is
the only product uh in the bathroom that
we're requiring as the state and that
triggers Our 28a obligation if we
mandate it we must pay for it and
I you know and those other things are
just great ideas to include the
provision of menstrual products and
those products were being provided long
before the state stepped in uh it's 100
years the schools have been taking care
of the problem uh without a state
mandate so
um so it the state initiated contact on
this issue and when we initiated contact
on this issue we incurred an obligation
to do our job
yeah
thank you a couple things I just got a
text about a large high school yesterday
you said the cost is no big deal and the
current program is working just fine but
that's not why I raised my hand but it's
a good it's a good point to consider
that it seems schools are doing just
fine right now
um apropos the other we sort of fund the
you know to a certain extent we are
funding toilet paper and paper towels
and all that other stuff through the
money that we give to the schools in our
you know adequacy but the state is
providing funding for this I can see
this being singled out because that for
a lot of people believe it or not this
is sort of a new idea and it's a little
bit of an edgy idea it's only fairly
recently that we're talking about this
um and I hate can I I just need to go
back to section five here about you know
doing the damage before this bill before
the bill that said that these products
needed to be provided
I'm sure there were girls who were
flushing pads down the toilet and
throwing them in the walls and all that
sort of stuff that is not a new problem
and schools have already been dealing
with those issues janitorial issues and
cleaning issues
as long as they're as long as this has
been going on so again I'm just
concerned about I don't think I don't
know why this is necessary to me it
confuses the issue I see both sides in
terms of the school funding these
products already and from what I've been
hearing it's just not a big deal for the
schools to pick up the cost it's not an
onerous Demand on the schools so I don't
know if we really need to go down this
path where I do see that there's value
to it is that it brings it to the
Forefront because this is a discussion
that has been frankly taboo for many
many decades and girls did not go to
school because they were embarrassed
they didn't want to go to the guidance
counselor this puts it within reach of
them so again I says I'm concerned I
don't know why we need to tell that the
schools can clean up when the kids have
made a mess because they've been doing
that since kids have been making messes
and
um we are funding all these products
through what we do through education and
it seems to me the schools are have been
taking up that cost for uh these
feminine products with the new one
without too much of a concern if it's
just a constitutional issue
to me that's
um
maybe being too sensitive about I know
how much the Constitution matters to you
and to me there's a little bit maybe of
an oversensitivity in terms of how the
original bill was written so
okay
thank you Mr chair I just want wanted to
the man that the reason why and I'm
gonna guess here but uh the reason why I
consider the uh section five on taking
appropriate action to preclude and
prevent vandalism and theft product
comes with State funding if we are gonna
fund for this we have to you know
clarify that when you receive those
funds to provide those things you have
an obligation to make sure they are used
appropriately I I would not think this
would be necessary if we didn't fund and
mandate this and in regards to this
being a minor you know uh Financial
impact be that as it may it's still an
unfunded mandate and if it's a minor
Financial impact on the school it will
be a very minor impact on the state
budget to do their job so I think the
amount is commensurate with you know the
mandates so yeah indeed they are not
either of them a huge deal but as a
matter of principle unfunded mandates
should not be allowed so thank you
coming just a quick response and I'm
afraid we might be going down a rabbit
hole here if you have a plugged toilet
you don't know whether the pad is from
the pad the girl brought from home or
whether it's a pet she got from school I
mean the toilet is plugged and it needs
to be fixed and I don't really see why
it is germane to this bill
okay the department of
who was here from
yes I'm not familiar with all the
thank you Mr chair my name is Barrett
Christine I'm the executive director of
the New Hampshire school boards
Association I don't know if I really
have anything to add other than I'm just
here listening to the conversation
um by way of background when the initial
bill
um uh was presented to the legislature I
forget two or three sessions ago nhsba
did not take a position on the bill
um we were caught in sort of a rock and
a hard place we wanted to be supportive
of young women in our schools but we
also shared representative Edwards
concerns that it was going to be an
unfunded mandate a lot of the testimony
at the time
um was from that from school districts
were saying we're already doing this we
built it into our own local budget the
concern about the impact of the bill
crossed nhsba's desk The Following fall
when the Manchester School District was
implementing it and the reports I got
from Manchester school boards was that
it cost them about a hundred and fifty
thousand dollars to implement this in
Manchester some of those were one-time
costs they had to buy the dispensers
that go on the wall or the door or
whatnot so the recurring costs for the
products the feminine hygiene products
themselves I don't know
um we did sign in support to uh uh the
bill yesterday to representative Edwards
Bill yesterday
um simply because if there are school
districts that were not doing this
before we're not paying for it out of
local funds but now we're being
obligated to do so
um uh because of the state mandate
whether from nhsba's position whether or
not that's one dollar or a hundred
thousand dollars per School District
it's a state obligation the state
mandate the state should pay for it to
the other points about
um paper towels and soap and toilet
paper again there's nothing explicit in
law that requires a school district have
toilet paper but we know that there's
been toilet paper in school since we've
had Public Schools
um what that's paid from I don't that's
a good question I don't I don't know if
any I don't know the attic was the
formula as well as I probably should I'm
guessing a lot of that would be local
money I don't think you're getting
adequacy aid for paper towels and but so
it's probably local money but regardless
of of of of of of the issue I'll sum up
um many districts were already doing
this prior to the law to the extent that
there was a fiscal impact on districts
that were not doing this as a result of
this legislation and this mandate and
hsba would support funding funding the
bill if you will
questions
yes
thank you Mr chair thank you Mr uh
Christina
um for taking my question
um are you aware what the cost is for
you know
in general I guess pick a district that
you're familiar with for students who do
miss school because of menstruation
products not being affirmatively
available and you know what what that
long-term cost might be as opposed to
the The Upfront cost of just providing
the product sure thank you very much for
the question representative well there's
um a non-tangible cost every time a
student misses school whether or not
that's a half a day one day or multiple
days how that's measurable I I don't
know um to be clear I'm not an educator
by trade I'm a lawyer by trade but we
have Educators that could probably talk
to for Johnny or this is not Johnny
Sally misses three days of school my
apologies if Sally misses three days of
school this may be the detrimental
impact on her education
would you believe that I think it's
probably more I believe that the cost
you know the tangible and intangible
costs may be more than just providing
the product it's certainly believable to
your question representative
thank you Mr chair thank you for
answering my question my concern is this
um for years we put into place any kind
of legislation
um schools right now are fulfilling this
if in fact
we decide to go forward with the bill as
is and the legislator legislature in
future years choose not to fund this
then what happens do school districts
just go back to not providing these
products for young women
um that's my big concern because we've
seen as we've heard time and time again
that there are lots of laws on the books
and one of the mechanisms to not really
fulfilling that piece of legislation is
simply to say we don't have available
funds to do it
so thank you for the question
representative
um
every time the state walks back for many
of the time any of its
um previous Financial Obligations the
local school districts and the local
taxpayers always pick up the dime New
Hampshire Retirement Systems special
education costs the list goes on and on
and on the the legislature cut funding
to the New Hampshire retirement system
local taxpayers are paying that
difference now I presume that's if the
law were taken off the books I would
think that districts would probably
still be providing these these products
for for young girls thank you thank you
thank you chairman just a quick
clarification right now we are in a
situation where we have the law and we
don't have the funding and the
experience shows that every school does
provide the products they just do it on
their own time I would not see any
reason any reason for a future School
District to walk back from providing
those products if we leave the law on
the books but we don't appropriate
correctly I would object to that but I
do not think that if a legislature makes
that decision however unwise I may think
that decision may be that will change
the impact it will change the
availability of the product but it will
change it is that will hurt school
districts will now have to deal with an
unfunded mandate so that's why I think
passing the bill is a good idea and that
you know it should make things better I
just don't really see this as creating
an extra risk thank you
thank you Mr chair uh let's not forget
that
um one of the reasons that this bill was
passed in the first place is that
because there were school districts who
were not providing appropriate products
they were not providing any products and
so
um to you know it was it was a this
becomes a real problem where girls can't
go to school but it's not true that
schools were already doing this some
schools were doing this but not all and
that was sort of the um the initial
reason for why this bill needed to be
put out in the first place is to make
sure that girls did have access to
quality products
Joe
uh thank you Mr chair uh if you remember
yesterday we had uh testimony from the
Auburn uh
superintendent I believe his
superintendent uh that uh
these these uh the reason that they just
they could uh cause a lawsuit you know
because of the 28-a issue but it was so
okay well the interesting part about
this this is my seventh year in finance
and it's the first year we had got this
many initial bills so we don't know how
to act uh what I do know is we don't
have a budget no we don't have a revenue
number yet as I said earlier so my my
recommendation is that we retain this
until we can find out can we fund it
because I don't know that I don't know
right now whether we can or not we're
talking about about two million dollars
I mean in the scheme of the five billion
dollar budget it's not a big deal but in
but in reality two million dollars is
still not chump change
uh so I would enter I would entertain
um okay move by uh Joe do we have a
second
what's up
okay Daniel we'll give you this this
round
oh okay so um we do have a motion to
retain and I'm gonna call the vote uh
representative Peter
yes uh representative Bean
yes uh myself yes representative buco
yes representative Heath
no representative Murray yes yes
representative hacken Phillips yes yes
and chairman Emery yes yes uh the motion
passes seven to one
okay so we'll continue to work on this
okay we'll close the hearing on 129 and
we're going to open up a hearing on
three bills because they're topically
are in the down the same path
and yes Mr chair I just have to excuse
myself to introduce another bill and
another committee and I apologize to the
committee that's all right it's that
okay
Nick you want to we do have Amy Clark
from the Department of Education here
she'll be our school building Aid expert
I think the division getting an overview
presentation about the program as it
currently is now would be a good start
and then we can start talking about
be good to know what we're talking about
welcome
you're off okay good morning my name is
Amy Clark and I'm with the Department of
Education I'm the administrator for the
school safety and facility management
Bureau uh I do have a presentation for
and actually that one too can go behind
thanks Mickey
foreign
I think the first packet I'll wait until
you have it to start talking but um the
first packet will probably look familiar
to you because I think that you were
handed out something uh similar from
representative Ladd
um his handout was from my presentation
to House Education
this presentation is almost identical
but hearing some questions I added I I
added a little bit more information here
and there based on some questions that
people had so
you can ditch that one and and use this
they really do look very similar same
okay so uh my the program uh you know
the packet that I'm talking about is
this one it's 11 pages
and it just has a table of contents on
it for you
and if you do get them shuffled in your
collection of information do you need
another
I apologize I would need two more
because we are talking about free bills
so I would need two more sets of
handouts so I can put one in each folder
thank you
uh so um if they do get shuffled about
um with yesterday's materials and these
just there is a revision date on the
bottom because they they do look very
identical and I'll point out some of the
changes along the way if if you care to
know what they are uh so uh I'm just
going to go through these
um and uh when I refer to page numbers
I'm talking about the page number in the
top right corner all of the documents
are pulled from different sources and
have their own page numbers because
they're posted on our website but for
this presentation there's 11 pages and
that page number is in the top corner so
I'll just start on page two well let me
flip page one my contact information is
on page one if you do need to contact me
there's my information there's uh who I
am and I'm happy building Aid is always
so much fun to talk about so feel free
to call me at any time uh page two is uh
when somebody asks me to put the
building aid program on one page I was
limited to one page this is the page
that it landed on there's a lot of
information on this one page and so this
is for the most part what I'm going to
talk to you about
kind of learning about the program a
little bit again more contact
information the laws RSA 19815 that is
where you'll find building Aid the
supporting education rules is under Ed
essentially the basics which I think
probably you all know at this point but
the basics are really building Aid is
state aid to Aid to help schools with
large construction or reconstruction
projects
we're not talking about there's another
fund called the public school
infrastructure fund that's a school
safety Grant those are like for smaller
safety Grant projects when we are
talking about building Aid we're really
talking about multi-million dollar large
construction projects or large
renovation projects and sometimes it
gets smaller if they're in addition but
they're still large projects
uh building a grants the state share in
law this is all what I'm going to talk
to you about is all in RSA 19815 is the
range is between 30 and 60 percent
there's a formula in 198 15 that
essentially has two functions it is the
calculation is a function of median
family income and equalized valuation
per pupil
some people have talked about the um the
rates of median family income being a
little questionable about whether median
family income is appropriate or not I
guess I just will point out that the um
the formula is the ranking of those
numbers so it doesn't necessarily matter
specifically what the number is in the
formula it just matters where you rank
in the state so every communities median
family income is ranked every
community's media uh equalized valuation
per pupil is ranked and the formula uses
those rankings to place them in a
category that ranges from 30 to 60
percent more affluent communities that
the 30 percent end less affluent
communities are at the 60 end I also
like to point out with this rate that it
is not a linear distribution the average
rate in new uh for the communities in
New Hampshire is 38 percent so
somebody finds themselves a 40 Community
they they kind of feel
um you know like they're they're not
they feel like they should be much
higher rate but really they are above
average more below average whichever way
you want to look at it uh so the average
rate is 38 currently
that formula gets calculated
um recalculated every year
the funding source is uh in the
education trust fund that's where you'll
find building aim
and I think when we talk about building
Aid it's really important to understand
the history of building Aid because
um of what well we'll talk about a
little later but there's um funds that
we're slowly paying off in the past so
it's important to understand what the
program used to look like because we're
still paying for those projects so
building Aid had been around since 1946
all the way to
um
2012.
um before we went into a moratorium the
moratorium went into effect actually in
2009 but the
um the law had been around I was a
building Aid was funded between 1946 and
2009 and in
in 2009 the state went into a moratorium
on building Aid and then in 2000 13 the
laws significantly changed so there was
a 10-year moratorium from 2009 to about
2019 where no projects were funded but
the law changed in the middle of that so
in 2013 the law changed uh in the old
um structure so from 1946 to 2012 there
was in the law was a structure that paid
the grants
the a portion of the principle on the
life of the Lo on the life of the bond
that the schools had
so if it was a 20-year bond that
building a grant was granted out for 20
years on the principle of that Bond if
they were a 30 Community it would pay 30
of the principal all the way throughout
in 2013 again it was during the
moratorium we weren't actually funding
projects but in 2013 uh the law was
changed to a different funding structure
and that funding structure said that
we're going to Grant the school a sum of
money using that same formula in the end
they received the same amount of money
but we're going to pay 80 percent of
that amount up front
and then 20 upon completion so School
construction project might take three
four years to finish then they would get
eighty percent of it up front they'd
finish the project submit all their
receipts and invoices and go through a
detailed review and then they would get
their 20 remaining at the end
so just just so I can grasp this so what
we were doing before is we were paying
it out over to 20-year life
and we decided it was a better idea to
pay 20 years worth of value in three to
four years
uh correct I think the thought was at
the time and I think probably still most
would agree
um that the that that way the
communities wouldn't have to take out uh
a large sum of money and have to pay
interest on that that the that they
could bond a less amount lesser amount
and not have to pay interest over 20
years because they got there
40 50 Grant up front
but that got us where we are now the
tear the paying out over the life of the
bond we're still doing that well it's
the old funding structure but we haven't
paid those off I I think I have a graph
that we'll go over in a little bit that
might help clarify that
um
strategically what we've done is we've
uh shot our feet off
so we can't do as much for as many
schools as we used to
I would uh I I would say that
um funding a few schools so that
eventually that tale will be paid off
right so I think at the time the
legislature felt and probably many still
do and I think I agree and I actually
think schools agree that getting a
larger amount up front uh to fund their
project is a much better savings to
their Community because they don't have
to bear all that interest out it is
always unfortunate in the beginning of
this structure because we're still
paying off these old projects and it
really is not pleasant to be the school
that doesn't receive funding so I'm sure
if you if when we run out of money all
the schools on the bottom of the list
probably would prefer to have the
funding structure the old way but
eventually the tail will go away and
eventually there will be a list of
projects and people will move up that
list and then they would get funded I
mean that's the way the model is
supposed to work but they have to
reapply
uh they don't necessarily have to
reapply uh
we're probably jumping ahead but when
the when an application comes in and
they get ranked they can stay on that
ranked list as long as they have the
support of their local community so if
the state runs out of money and it's the
state's fault they don't get funded then
they stay on the list if the community
doesn't want the project then they get
bumped off the list I won't interrupt
anymore please yeah no no that's why I
love questions I just
um so here's a quick example
um on here the the numbers are right
there but I just thought a very easy
example would be just to say like
comparing the old funding to the new
funding and when I say new I mean from
2013 that
um it's not new so much anymore but the
uh let's say a school district takes out
a 20-year bond for 40 million dollars
and let's say uh so if you want to
follow along on the example it's in the
middle of page two
so the example is a school district has
a 40 million dollar project they take
out a 20-year bond for it in the old
structure let's assume that there are 50
even though I said 38 is the average
rate we're all better with 50 as a
number so let's assume that there are 50
community and they're getting 50 state
aid and 50 percent uh coming with their
local local funding so on a 40 million
dollar School the state pays 20 million
the local community pays 20 million
and that's the same under both
structures the grant is still 20 million
dollars in both structures in the old
structure uh what would happen is over
the life of 20 years they would get that
20 million dollars 1 million each year
and they would be done doesn't exactly
work that way because principles change
and so forth but in this General example
they get one million dollars for 20
years and that's how they get their 20
million dollars in the new structure
the school district gets that 20 million
dollars almost up front so and their 40
million dollar project they're going to
get a 20 million dollars of state aid
they're going to get that 80 percent of
that up front so they're going to get 16
million dollars of state aid up front
and then once they complete the project
they can get their remaining four
million dollars uh so that's how that
new structure works and you can imagine
for for a local community instead of
taking out a 20-year Bond they only now
are taking out uh uh 20-year Bond I'm
sorry for
a 40 million dollar Bond over 20 years a
40 million dollar Bond now they're only
taking out a
24 million dollar Bond actually they'd
probably be taking out a 20 million
dollar Bond and having a short-term
construction loan for that piece that
they're waiting for the the remaining
state to come in so that's the big
difference for schools instead of a 40
million dollar Bond they're really
seeking a 20 million dollar bond out
uh
so in 20 so now so another thing it's
important to um no in 2013 the other big
change wasn't this funding structure but
also there was a cap on building Aid so
not only do you now have the brand new
funding structure but in 2013 all of a
sudden there was a cap on building AIDS
so that is where that cap that you hear
people talking about in the bills that
you have in front of you is that 50
million dollar cat prior to 2013 that
did not exist
how schools applied for building Aid is
that they would put an application I
just want to make sure that you are
clearly listening to this piece it's
very interesting schools applied for
building Aid we collected the
applications we tallied up that amount
we told the legislature this is the
amount the schools need based on their
rates the 30 60 rates and the
legislature funded that amount
so from 1946 all the way to 2009 that
was the structure a couple of years it
was a shortfall we only got like 93
percent of the amount and we prorated
everybody down but for the most part
um building Aid was fully funded and met
the needs that the schools requested
in 2013
um the cap was put on a 50 million
dollars no more than 50 million dollars
of building Aid and so we were still in
a moratorium we finally come out of a
moratorium in 2000
20. I'll just say 2020 we came out of a
moratorium and and
um
with that cap amount now you can see
that we have a cap we have to have some
kind of competitive structure like how
do we determine who gets this money now
that it's
um capped and so that funding those I'm
sorry the ranking criteria and how we
rank the projects is now listed in law
overcrowding
Ada deficiencies Life Safety
consolidation
security all of that is now ranked in
law it states those criteria the ranking
points are actually in rule but the
criteria are in in the law so that is
how we determine who gets that 50
million dollars before we didn't have to
do that because there was no cap now
that there's a cap that's how those are
determined so then there's a list of
projects that come out that are ranked
by the department verified by the school
building authority published by the
State Board of Education and then that
that list is produced and then that
amount of funding just goes to the top
school if they pass their local
community wants to build the project the
state will provide their share and it
moves down until people say yes or no
um
for example last biennium the rank one
project did not pass I think it was
ranked three and four I might be getting
that mixed up but it wasn't the top
ranked project it did move down the list
until a local community passed a warrant
article to accept those funds
uh you did mention about how to stay on
that list you do stay on that list from
by it's a biennium list because our
funding comes as you know in two years
so we're able to get let's say some
amount of money in year one allocate it
and some in year two and continue to
allocate it and then the list somewhat
starts over new people can apply to be
on the list those people that um have
support from their local communities
meaning they passed a warrant article uh
or got their District's legislative body
approval in the city's cases then they
move up you when we take new
applications they stay in that ranked
order those new applications can get
bumped only if we receive projects with
higher life safety concerns so they
could bump some projects down
[Music]
um
I think it's well I'll I'll mention that
after Okay so this building Aid funding
history this last piece on the bottom
um is the kind of the history of
um building Aid so you can see the the
top green line is 1946 to 2009 that
represents about uh 63 years money was
appropriated to meet demand again
schools applied
uh and the state funded their portion
the local community funded their portion
and so forth
in 2010 to 2019 that's that 10-year
moratorium uh one project was funded in
2018 the in-house Bill 2 they lifted the
moratorium funded this one emergency
project so technically in 2018 there
wasn't a moratorium but for all intents
purposes the 10-year moratorium but you
will see like moving across in that
table it um you'll see the number one
there it just means that during that 10
years one project was funded the project
um cost was 3.6 million dollar project
uh the state's portion for that
particular project was 2.2 million
dollars
um of the one project that was applied
one project was funded
uh and then that last column is
um the amount of building Aid that was
appropriated
um plus the amount that was granted to
new projects uh that column is going to
make a little more sense when we talk
about the tail a little bit but the 53
million do you see where that says 53
million on that that sheet that's for
the past projects those are for projects
that were already built but we're paying
on their bond amounts so that's the 53
million for past projects 2.2 million
dollars for the new project
in the blue here is where we're out of
the moratorium the moratorium no longer
exists in law so
um that first year of the moratorium the
first year out of the moratorium was the
biennium of 2021 five we received five
applications
uh the total project cost for those five
projects was 45 million dollars they
were see if they were all funded they
were seeking 17 million dollars of state
aid
three of them were funded two of them
did not pass their warrant articles
um so for that biennium 40 million
dollars was used to pay for past
projects
8.6 million dollars of the 17 million
dollar request was funded
um for those three projects uh
I'll continue down the line but then
um biennium we're in right now
um we received 12 applications they were
requesting 227 million dollars the total
project cost was 227 million dollars
they were requesting 140 million in
state aid
um we received enough Aid to fund two of
those 12 and you can see the the past
projects was 33 million dollars new
projects was 30 million dollars
for the next biennium the one that you
all are here for
um the 70 we received 17 applications
you have to apply a year in advance so
that's why we already know this number
17 projects applied the total amount of
project costs for that was 564 million
the state portion of that is 227 million
and the number of applications funded of
course is to be determined because we
don't have a budget yet uh so assuming
past projects are funded we would be
funding 26 million dollars for our past
projects and
um
money for new projects which is to be
determined
so that is my program on one page I
won't talk that much on all the other
pages but I will go through them quickly
um
page three and Page four are just the
building Aid rates if you're interested
in knowing what communities get what
rates that's where that's at
page five I believe you may have seen
this so this is one of the sheets that
was edited if you wanted to if you saw
this sheet before I've added the totals
I think there were questions about and
how said there were questions for me
about what the totals of these columns
were so that's really the only
difference here is the totals are on the
bottom but this graph does tell quite a
bit of a story
um about building AIDS so I'll just walk
through it real quickly the bar on the
bottom the dark color bar the Bottom bar
is our obligated payments to schools
that's we're paying on those 20-year
bonds still in some cases was a 30-year
a couple of 30-year bonds so we're
paying a portion of that and you can see
it gets smaller and smaller that's
because we're continuing to pay off
projects every year people fall off the
list in 2041 we won't be paying any more
of that old funding structure and
um
the light blue bar is in 2010 uh the
state
um
couldn't meet I don't really know what
the appropriate word was it wasn't
around in my position at the time but
didn't meet their obligations to schools
so they decided in 2010 to take out a
bond in order to meet those obligations
to schools so the state has a bond
from paying projects in 2010. so that
blue portion is not payment to schools
it's the state's debt for paying a bond
in 2010 that we took out to pay Our
obligation to schools
a lot of people are not pleased with
that practice for the state to take out
a bond to pay schools to pay on their
bond so that is now prohibited in law
just so you know we can't do that
anymore
um but that is the payment on our the
um the
past Mark it's a bar that's white with a
little hash over it you can see it kind
of jumps all around that is this that is
this new projects that we've funded
under the new new
post 2013 or really post 2020
um
funding mechanism that 80 20. so that's
why there's these little shots of money
so in 2020 the moratorium was lifted we
put 6.7 million dollars for building Aid
then the F the second year of the
biennium it was 1.9 million the in 2022
30 million was given 2023 no money was
given
um you you can see also on that graph
that the graph goes up to 50 million
dollars on the y-axis it goes up to 50
million and that's because that's what
our cap is so that's why I kind of
depict it that's the ceiling that's in
the law well you can see in 2022 we went
above that ceiling that's because in
House Bill 2 they lifted that cap just
for that one year and then closed it
again so
um we're allowed to go over just for
that one year and what really happened
is just a very quick question you were
saying that the number is zero for the
new project for Appropriations for new
projects for 23 is that the final number
because we are still six months into the
year I just want to make sure and yeah
it's a final number this is but
amount Grant this is amount appropriated
got it which in general does granted but
yeah so the appropriation was zero and
really what happened in my opinion what
happened was that there were two stacks
meeting about 50 million dollars and let
maybe last minute conversations were
just like we'll just front load this
we'll take year two money and put it in
year one
um if you add up
um well I'll just leave it at that I
think that that money from year two was
just shifted to year one so that's the
current biennium we're in right now and
as you can see we don't know what the
future holds for 24.25
um so there's nothing there at this
point
um those numbers are also in this chart
here you can see the fiscal year you can
see the obligated um I'll just take you
through the columns here the that second
column is that those past payments to
schools that we all want their their
past project payments then you can see
our building Aid Bond payment that's the
state Bond payment you can see it ends
in 2030. we took it out we started
paying out in 2010 2030 so it was a
20-year Bond
um
the total obligations just we call that
our obligations is our past project
payments plus our state Bond it doesn't
feel like there's any way to get around
those past obligations so that's the
total there and then the law states the
cap that
um the legislature can't appropriate any
more money than 50 million dollars less
our obligations uh therefore when
schools ask me how much building Aid are
we going to get this year the number
ranges from zero to 22.6 million dollars
for for new projects that's the 50
million dollars less our obligations
but because we're a biennium list what I
really like to tell schools is the
bigger picture is what we're going to
get in the biennium so that last column
um is just the total for the biennium so
48.7 is the the
fiscal 24 plus fiscal 25. so
that 48.7 I'll just leave it with this
that 48.7 if school said if building Aid
is fully funded with the current law how
much is the State Department of
Education going to have to Grant out to
for new construction projects and I
would tell them 48.7 million dollars
that's assuming 50 million gets
appropriated in year one 50 million is
appropriated into year two that's 100
million they're always surprised that I
don't say 100 million but it's because
we have our past obligations that we
make payments and the remaining amount
is 48.7 of that 100 million in the
biennium
so let's see can I ask of course share
why did why did the 50 million dollar
cap appear I I don't know I don't know
um I do have a handout on what
um
on what might be in a I won't say
appropriate number but a number
um but I don't know what why that 50
million was determined at the time at
the time we were paying more than 50
million dollars the
um we were granting about 60 I think in
the highest um highest years maybe high
50s low 60s
so there's no does anybody have any
logic about why the cap was put on it I
am right oh okay that I think that was
okay
um
right
yes a quick question just so I can
understand because we're there's always
the talk about paying off the tail I
understand the obligated payments of the
schools goes across a bazillion
different schools in the state and
that's very complicated uh the building
Aid bond that we have is that something
that we could pay off is is that a one
thing that could be paid off or is that
as convoluted as the payments to the
schools unfortunately I don't know the
answer to that that like that question
would be a good question for the State
Treasury that money actually just goes
right to the state treasury I'm not
familiar with their bond but they I'm
sure would be able to tell you the
uh thank you oh just just a second uh to
answer that question I believe that was
answered yesterday and I believe that's
a there's a number of bonds out there
that
it's it's a it's a number and be very
complicated to pay the uh bonds off
just further clarify
um I did Finance bonds when I was the
town finance director through the bond
bank and those bonds cannot be paid
ahead of time this the structure is set
and the investors will not accept early
payments I do not have knowledge over I
think that answer was referring though
just to the obligated payment to schools
which are mostly through the Bond Bank I
think we do have to follow up with the
treasurer to inquire how our building
and bond building a point statements
that are structured that would may be a
different answer
I've seen the bar I have the only
information is that I've seen the bond
schedule and to me the schedule looks
like it's one Bond but they would be it
could be a series of them so
um but on the school's end which I know
was not your question but on the but the
obligated payments to schools are
multiple bonds and I do know from
conversation for the municipal Bond Bank
that those cannot be paid off early but
the treasury might be able to better
inform you about those um the state Bond
so let's see then moving along page six
seven
and eight is the fiscal these are the
applications that we received for fiscal
24 fiscal 25 funding these are the new
projects that want to construct and
applied for state aid those are in
ranked order
um I I want to make one
um somebody asked to really I went back
and listened to to you all yesterday and
I'm sorry that I was not able to attend
but
um one I I just want to make one
important clarification the the last
column is simply well the last three
columns are numbers right the first one
is estimated project cost this is taken
right from the applicants application
the the school building Aid rate is
their rate based on their municipality
the estimated building Aid is simply
those two numbers multiplied together
that's it what has not happened at this
time yet is that we have not gone
through these applications to determine
what's eligible and what is not that's a
that's a long process
um so somebody was asking the question
about
um project four versus project five
Concord versus Litchfield and was making
comparisons between those two schools
schools can apply for building Aid and
put much more in their application that
is not eligible for billing Aid so just
because that number let's just take
conquered for example is to 176 million
dollar project times 40 percent is
seeking 70 million dollars in Aid that
doesn't mean that they qualify or are
eligible for that amount of Aid and and
Concord school district is aware of that
and I know um
um Jack Dunn is behind me so he could
confer or confirm cooperate uh my that
story but anyway so I just want to say
that the schools this is their total
project and they're going to want as
much as eligible as not but we do
building a does cap costs
um per square foot building it also caps
um square foot per pupil and schools
oftentimes bring more programs I know
some schools have larger music programs
or certain things might be really
important to their District but that
doesn't necessarily mean that the state
pays for them so just keep in mind that
this this is a raw calculation it's
noted as a little footnote at the bottom
uh of this but in eventually we'll have
better numbers for these schools and
that's correct um so for example I don't
know of any schools but a school is more
you know a community may want to have a
strong swimming program and put a
swimming pool in the state's not going
to pay for a swimming pool but um you
know they're going to put their total
project in and we're going to go through
it and state what's eligible and what's
not
um the the big key to remember is that
there is a large portion
um of space the states square foot per
pupil is much smaller than what schools
are building across the board this is in
any one school schools are building
about 170 to 200 square feet per pupil
and the average square footage is about
140 square feet uh per pupil so just a
heads up this is the max most of these
schools won't be reaching their Max
um
just for note taking purposes could you
remind me what is the state square foot
limit and what is the average
construction because I want to make sure
I catch that sure um
say with the average construction costs
are because they are cheaper footage
um the square footage I'd say the
average is 140 square feet per pupil
however it varies
um because the law has
um three sets of square foot Elementary
Middle High and then they also have
smaller
um if you're less than 250 students in
your school you qualify for more square
feet per pupil because you imagine a gym
cafeteria those sizes don't change so
there are actually six numbers in the
law but the average is about 140.
and that compares with what's currently
built you know what's currently built
when we take and look at our last
handful we don't have a lot of data
because we haven't been building a lot
of schools but when we look at our past
handful of projects we're looking at
anywhere from like
170 to about 200 square feet per pupil
thank you yeah
and I'd say most schools are um are
really providing
um much more intensive special education
services
that are really difficult to get into
that square footage I I would say that
the special education spaces in schools
is much larger than what those Square
foots would allow that's usually what's
driving that maker spaces breakout
spaces collaboration spaces things like
that
they're not big grandiose atriums and um
and things like that so
um page 9 10 and 11 and
um I have you on the home stretch here
um page 9 10 and 11
um if you have the old packet there was
an um an error in there I thought I was
saving time by just hiding fiscal 23
payments in fiscal 24 which was fine
except that it messed up my total
remaining payments column we've paid
those payments so you don't really need
to follow that just know that this is
the updated worksheet
um and that total pay remaining payments
column includes fiscal 23 payments on
your last sheet so this one should be
corrected this one is corrected and this
is simply those tail payments we talked
about so and 20 this is all the past
project payments so if you're wondering
what school districts are getting
building aid for past projects this is a
list of those projects uh in order by
School District
and that
is almost the conclusion of my
presentation
um I I have one other sheet for you this
is separate
um from because you're the finance group
I thought I would throw a few more
numbers at you
um uh representative Emrick that's
already asked about that 50 million
dollars where does that come from I
think yesterday I don't know if it was
you as well to ask somebody's like oh
there's people just picking these
numbers out of the sky I I don't know
where those numbers come from but if
somebody asked me to write on a napkin
and do a calculation I'd love to do a
big study I don't have any money for a
big study so I have my napkin
calculation and to me it's all just
numbers so I'll take you through what I
think is the amount schools will spend
how much the state shared local share
that's really all up to the state right
I'm just stating this is what I think
schools are um spending for regular
what's in the law
for costs so in the state we have
roughly these numbers are rounded for
this this is not precise but 450 schools
in New Hampshire Public Schools
165 000 students K through 12 students
doesn't include the preschool students
because building Aid is just for K-12 by
the way so that's another square footage
that somebody could be putting preschool
rooms in their building and we would
actually prorate those spaces out
because building AIDS specifically in
the law says it's K-12 spaces uh 165 000
students is our roughly our current
enrollment
200 uh 23 million square feet this isn't
the actual amount of square feet by the
way this is the square footage based on
what the law allows us to build so
that's that 140 square feet per student
times 165
000 students so some might say this is
the the state's share of square footage
um uh average 140 square feet per
student that's based on law
um and then the average cost of a
project is somewhere about 550 a square
foot this number is wildly changing uh
this number is varies because we also
pay for site site developments sites you
can imagine a a land in Concord is going
to cost well much different than
something in kowas County
um and you're also if you've got ledge
that's going to drive some costs up
permitting costs um so forth so
um but in general this is a very rough
number 550 a square foot
um
40 years before a major renovation is
needed and when if you think about your
own home letting it go for 40 years
without doing a major renovation we're
not talking building Aid is not talking
about paint replacing Windows replacing
the roof replacing the boiler all of
those things use some of those things
were covered in the old building aid but
the new building Aid does not pay for
operation and maintenance they don't pay
for new roofs they don't pay for new
doors we're talking about rebuild so
when we talk about Renovations once
every 40 years or so we're talking about
studs are showing you're you're building
is gutted and that's the area that would
be eligible for building Aid so 40 years
in reality that's probably pushing to 50
years but ideally you really see a lot
of degradation beginning in 40 years so
I would say 35 to 40 years but I'll I'll
use 40 on that end
so this is my napkin calculation 23
million square feet 400 550
um per square foot leaves you with 12.7
billion dollars every 40 years so you
take that and divide it by 40 you end up
with 318 million dollars per year of
costs again some could argue that well
renovation might not cost as much some
could argue that renovation sometimes
costs more
um 318 million per year the average rate
per law is 38 percent so that would be
120 million dollars per year so 50
probably isn't covering it
um but again just a it's a calculation
to give you a ballpark of numbers that
you might be looking at
um
and I I think I already mentioned this
this just remember this calculation is
not based on the actual square footage
of buildings that we have in New
Hampshire we actually don't know because
we don't have an inventory
um of of that but
um when you hear people talk about
declining enrollment or so forth this
number is based on the current
population of students the actual space
is much bigger there's CTE spaces as
well that are not captured here as well
and then the last in the red it's very
important to remember that building a
does not cover operation and maintenance
so schools are you know when we talk
about deferred maintenance
um projects are scored based on if they
take properly if they could take good
care they're required to take good care
of their building if they receive
building Aid
um but if that's not covering those
costs so again roof boiler all of those
things are being paid by the school some
um there is an estimate typically in the
facility World they say operation and
maintenance over the life of the
building is about the cost of the
building so if the building costs 40
million dollars in general over that 40
years the building is around it's going
to cost the school district about 40
million dollars over that same life of
the building to operate and maintain it
so just some numbers for you to think
about and I am happy
to be answering any questions they might
have
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my questions very good
presentation appreciate that uh
I know you just mentioned that uh the
number of the population is decreasing
do you have any projections
anywhere that uh demographers have
um I don't I mean we've lost what
approximately 60 000 in the last 10 15
years right I don't
um the only thing I'll say to that is a
lot of our projects our consolidation
projects
um and the only last thing I'll say is
um my my small comparison of bridges uh
still need to be safe just even though
there's less traffic over them so the
buildings themselves we still have
students still I know that that's wasn't
your question but I'll just uh add add
to that when I can
foreign
to that point you know certainly it's
true that the population you know the
student population has been decreasing
but there are school districts where
population is increasing and to have
didn't you know to lump it into one
bucket doesn't tell a very good story in
terms of other school districts where
the school population is increasing so
it'd be nice to kind of have a sense of
where is the decline and where is the
increase
they will also when you go into these
schools there are definitely schools you
can see oh this got some empty space and
so forth but a lot and those schools are
probably talking maybe consolidation or
at least when they do get ready to build
a building a smaller school but there's
also
a lot of schools even though they have
less population are stuffed at the seams
and you can tell because they have
classrooms in the hallways but their
special education needs are so different
than what they were back when they were
I think that was wonderful I have to say
I Ed Murdo was like my guy for so long
and you just I'm still the new ad even
though he's been gone for a long time
I'll always be the new Ed right I've
been to the apartment for seven years
and I'm still the new ad yes so
um
I think
I think I have to preface my comments I
think there's a desire to provide more
building Aid to
um the budget
um
what would it be like let's say if we
put 60 million dollars in each year of
the biennium but we subtract it out and
set up another line
for those costs that we are committed to
from Years Gone by so that building Aid
would become a new viable entity with
the costs in another
line within the budget would you think
that would feel like walk like and talk
like uh well I know that you have a bill
um sponsored by representative Cahill I
believe
um with um with retro funding so correct
me if I'm wrong that's what you're
talking about is funding projects that
were in that moratorium or no no no no
I'm I well that was going to be my other
question though I was going to ask you
after this question this question
relates to just what you're talking
about new projects so that we would be
walking into the biennium with if we're
if the legislature if we're saying we
want to provide 60 million dollars each
year of the biennium for new projects
but we recognize the fact that we still
have our former obligations and I really
do want to follow up with the treasury
about that Bond because
um I'm curious but I'm afraid we'll
probably get the same answer but we have
to I think it's a good thing to ask that
question
but would it
would it make it simpler or more
confusing to go at it that way
by separating giving you new money
but keep maintaining our obligations but
keeping that separate
right
um
for me
um it won't it won't matter in my sense
of how we operate our program because
the requirement is that we pay off the
schools first before we fund new
projects that's already in there but I
can see conversationally wise
um it would be easier to discuss and a
little bit easier for schools to
understand for me the the biggest thing
for schools I think is not knowing how
much is available for new projects
because you don't build a school
overnight you don't design a school so
this would help you in the sense of
having a separate bucket of money
non-lapsing continuingly funded bucket
that certainly would help the school
districts apply for building Aid now can
I now I'll go to representative Cahill's
question
in his legislation he's asking for a
but
um with that thought in mind
my question is number one did those
projects ever go to the Department of Ed
I don't know it's not right
um so they were never some hurdles there
priced out on
allowable
expenses
so
and
we never seem to have an appetite well
let me ask this question when projects
went forward
did every every single School District
was fully notified that there would be
the moratorium was on and there would be
no funding available
I'm sorry I'm not sure I follow your
question back in the moratorium during
the moratorium years
so are you asking do they have a heads
up on the moratorium did they have a
full understanding of that uh I I don't
know my guess is when a when a again I
wasn't here but my guess is when you
have a project that the a program that's
funded since the for 60 plus years and
then someone says there's going to be a
two-year pause on the program my guess
is that schools were probably hopeful it
would come back but that two-year
moratorium was repeated five years and
then at some point school districts
probably
Pro my guess is not a lot of
construction took place in the beginning
of the moratorium because people were
hoping that the more time would end
um but then the program completely
changed and I'm sure some communities
went forward
um when when we were in a moment but
they never sent you any paperwork no we
did not receive applications nothing
went through the department of Ed not
officially there are always people
sending us courtesy copies of plans and
so forth which we always appreciate but
there was no open application process so
if if retro funding was
um open I
it's not going to be really easy to fund
those projects but I'm sure that we
could develop rules and regulations on
how to accept projects for old old
things that are 10 years old
um it won't be easy but it's not that it
can't be done with some kind of
um
thank you thank you Mr chairman
um Amy I want to thank you for on page
two the chart the history this this is
the best simplification I've seen as far
as
for the history of it okay
um and just one other thing is the the
uh the 80 20 that I think we're still in
now correct that came out of just
desperation because because nothing
because they were it was the moratorium
was on
and so to come out of that moratorium
that's that's when that 80 20 program
started I don't think so I mean
representative umberger
um previously has stated that that that
is by Design and that people are very
fond of the 80 20. I know there was a
comment yesterday that I listened to
about going back to the tale I don't I
don't think that's a good idea
personally I don't think that that's
what schools want I think schools want
to be able to bond a lower amount save
on interest rates and that they will be
patiently waiting in line when they
don't have to pay interest on their bond
um when that comes I think people on the
lower on the list would love to have
that tail broken out because then they
could get funded early on but I don't
think it was a part of desperation I
think it was a way to save communities
on paying all that interest on that Bond
thank you
just to add to those remarks I prefer
that the state takes care of its
obligations up front this hole let's
spend 20 years paying what we committed
to pay today not only is more expensive
because you know there is more interest
to be paid because the whole amount has
to be bonded and then we only pay the
principal but the interest still has to
be paid by the schools but frankly it's
a way to shift the expenses that we make
today to be paid by taxpayers 20 years
from now
personally I think that the people who
support the expenses should be the ones
that pay for it so I understand this
frustrates the schools that don't make
it and maybe at some point the
legislature will want to consider that
based on uh you know the you know one
page summary here we seem to have a hard
time
basically I don't see this tale of
projects that get rejected getting
smaller based on this you know rough
rough estimate so maybe structural
changes will be needed in the law maybe
we'll need to look at another way to
provide this help but
whenever we pay whenever we make
promises I think most of the funding
should come you know when the project is
done not be shifted to uh you know
decades later just my personal thought
of
other comments
I have a chair of the school building
authority
you would ask what would make it you
ought to come up to a mic sorry about
that
you can say okay we work well together
yeah we do
um so as as a chair of the school
building authority and and this chair no
I'm good
um from Australian so I'm used to
sitting like this this is fine
um oh thank you very much
so um I in in response to uh
representative Heath's comment of what
would make Amy's job easier I think it's
very important and and she mentioned it
but it kind of slid right by
um
I for years have been
complaining about the process the
process is awful the timeline is awful
the amount of applications that come in
at one time and she has a period of time
to review those applications before she
gets them to me to all for the school
building authority to review before I
have to report to the board of ed
is about a six-month window
so when you saw those 17 applications
that came in this year
it's important for me to point out that
those 17 hadn't had not been approved by
their Community yet
so Amy is doing all of the work of
evaluating all 17 projects meaning site
visits reviewing plans all of that
for projects that many of them that the
community may have no support for and no
interest in doing so it would seem to me
if there was a way of jiggering the
timeline and it may mean that we push
this out to a a longer process
but if there was a way that we knew the
community had interest in it and had the
ability to to pay their
you know 70 or or 30 percent of the of
the cost up front that would relieve
looking at process at projects that
aren't going to go anywhere anyway you
know aren't aren't of Interest I happen
to live this because it was my school
district last term that came out number
one on the on the process but the
community voted it down so you know I
saw all of the additional work that Amy
had to go through and her team
when it was never going to be anything
that was of Interest or or past the
community so I think that is a
more so you've seen all the numbers and
all of them I I don't dispute
um that Amy's given you here
processes the bigger problem
um it's not the money and and I keep
seeing the bills coming through saying
let's put more money into this
the process is awful so you're putting
money into something that that isn't
it's indeterminate it isn't working the
way it is as it is is it in statute or
is this a just a adoptive process no
it's interesting yeah
um we have for years talked about trying
to
get the stakeholders together and figure
out a better timeline and I think there
is a bill by representative Ladd I'm not
happy with that either but that's
neither here nor there but there there
needs to be a better way that we do that
if we in fact are going to do building a
that's okay
thank you Mr chair do you have a sense
of how many of the projects are totally
tossed out because they're just not
eligible or is it always just part of
the project and secondly um you know
these have to go to Warren which is town
meeting and you know that sort of thing
is there a halfway measure of being able
to take the the temperature of the
community in order to get a sense that
probably the community will support it
because I think communities will resist
voting for a warrant if they have no
idea whether they're going to get
anything proposed anything approved it's
a chicken or egg thing isn't it uh I
mean you're thank you for your question
it is I don't think there is any way of
us predetermining what percentage of
those 17 are going to be approved or not
approved
but I think there would have to be some
kind of a way that in the warrant you
would have to have it built into a
contingency process if if building Aid
was available would you approve if if it
wasn't would you approve and then you've
got another bigger question
um
what's the obligation of residents in
Coos County to have to support
the construction of a elementary school
in Nashua when Nashua is planning to do
it anyway you know whether there's
building Aid or not you know you you've
got a
it's it's difficult to spend well
it's really easy to spend other people's
money but this is
um asking other parts of the state to
support a school where those places may
be willing to build their school anyway
and though that the
um
I I do feel like the communities have
put an investment in the application
though so they have had to appropriately
or budget a certain amount of money to
put in an application for hiring an
architect and preliminary plans I would
agree that the process the bill
representative Vlad has in kind of flips
it a little
um and I think that will help out the
process but I guess I would just point
out that the
um
for me I look at this list of 17 schools
and feel like all the 17 schools uh
certainly were worthy of the
Department's time I think that they were
ranked appropriately I I really um this
is a you know we've only been through
this really three times now and I did
feel like having a large group of
applications the feel of it you know you
do get into a school and you're kind of
like oh you don't know how the points
are going to shake out but it does feel
appropriate so I was pleased with that
and the law not that there aren't tweaks
that can't be made
um but I just want to point out that the
communities do have to put up front some
fairly significant meaning a hundred
thousand maybe even up to two hundred
thousand dollars in order to apply for
these because they are hiring our an
okay
do you have another question
I want to actually concur with what um
Amy's saying as a former assistant
superintendent we often especially in a
small town when they can only vote once
a year on to secure a bond or not a lot
of work and effort goes in and sometimes
we used to say three times a charm so it
it doesn't always work the first time
but we kept we used to keep going back
and building more consensus across it's
a good it's a good way to build
consensus and bring the community
together too to get that Bond
thank you
um
again offer myself as the chair of the
school building authority if you have in
information or you have questions on
that I can provide information on I'm
happy to do that we'll be back I'm sure
thanks thank you
all set from YouTube or yeah likes it
all right excellent presentation thank
Michael what do you got well first of
all I want to second that that was a
wonderful presentation I've seen a few
of Amy's uh presentations and it's a
difficult difficult complicated mess
that uh you're getting getting a chance
to fix it uh probably not this time but
uh in any case I think part of the
problem is the is the cap
and if we didn't have the cap then
school it wouldn't be competitive we
could still rank them and say which ones
will do first but a town like like uh
like Claremont where they where they you
know three different votes and they were
one short or one you know
that's all it takes is one one person
stays home watching Dancing with the
Stars and you lose the whole thing and
there's a lot of effort goes into it
so I think the cap is the problem uh my
bills has at least 60 million 60 million
minimum per year which I think is a is a
good starting point yes we have to pay
down the debt uh I I wrote to Mr Caswell
and trying to push for uh some of this
arpa go for money to enable us to do
more schools you know on the current
list but I don't want to I don't want to
overlook the people uh in New Market and
in in Windham and in uh so many other
communities that went forward when
applications were not accepted
uh but we did often as as Amy said we
we've submitted plans and we tried to
stay in line with what the what the
department would accept and was you know
with the standards I know that Mr uh
Mullen was here earlier they did the
same thing with the school they built in
Middleton
so you know the the districts have
worked at this uh the people in the
community uh the the reason that the 80
20 was done was to try to incentivize
people make it easier less expensive for
them over time and here in New Hampshire
sometimes nothing is going to be enough
to get some people to vote for something
that will cost any money at all
um
you know I'm a I'm working on a bill for
my next turn for next year which would
change the uh what we say on the license
plate for from uh Live Free or Die to if
it's free that's for me
I think it's kind of catchy
but uh you know we we just have to you
know education is important it gets to
work for us it gets to people who are
here having businesses starting
businesses working in businesses uh we
want our kids to stay here and be
educated do all the trades and all the
things that we need to have done they
have to go to school and we have to
build and maintain the schools and so I
hope that you will I understand you're
going to work through all these bills
and find the best possible solution it
could be pieces of this and pieces of
that and I wish you the best of luck and
I appreciate all the work you're going
to put into it
thank you
okay
uh I would like to consider did you want
to make yeah sure thank you sir I
my name is Jack Dunn I'm the business
administrator for the Concord school
district and uh I I will speak the same
comments as it relates to Amy Clark
she's been fantastic to work with we
really appreciate her in-depth knowledge
for her and her small Department over
there having to uh take care of
everything we are ranked number four on
the list so as you heard the funding for
the first three the fourth one we're
just peeking in the window but uh just a
couple comments and observations as I
was at the bill yesterday for
representative Wallner for uh Bill 541
to fund it at 100 million per year
and I'm sure there's a lot of different
competing bills but I just want to kind
of mention some things based on what I
heard and some maybe ideas uh as far as
dealing with enrollment both
representatives are right you do have
declining enrollment but some towns will
go up and some are staying steady uh the
Concord example is we did a demographic
study in 1819 and everything shows for
us flattening out
now they're only good for five years why
is it five years you go back five years
from a five-year-old that's when the
baby's born you nothing is reliable
after this five years so we're coming up
on doing again
um here in Concord we're having
significant development there's about
241 units coming in to conquer between
where the proposed Concord steam was
going to go and some other parts of the
city so that will affect our schools and
diff excuse me different ways but I also
in our demographic study we were being
equated to Portland Maine and Salt Lake
City Utah where we are getting what
they're calling dinks dual income no
kids okay
um people are either having kids later
or they're not having them at all so I
don't think we're going to see the
serious influx but I think as Miss Clark
had mentioned before Bridges age whether
there's more cars or fewer cars schools
age whether there's more kids or fewer
kids it's all mechanical systems weather
we're in a really tough environment
especially in the next couple hours that
may start up again so
um they just need to be the school
buildings will need to be addressed
all right
thank you Mr chair Mr Dunn while you are
here and since you are from Concord and
there were questions about the uh
rather High Cost of that school is that
something that you know you could give
the committee a bit more information
about so we understand the Dynamics
behind that because I have to say that's
quite an eye-popping number so you know
I I agree and I was going to address
that but I'll go right to that so that
176 million is based on estimates by a
uh estimator for the architect that we
hired our scope of work to prepare this
application was 393 thousand dollars so
as they were talking about communities
made investment
communities make significant investments
into these applications to get in line
which honestly I think they should
because they need to make the commitment
and show the state hey if we're willing
to back you you got to show the
commitment you're willing to do the work
to get there I totally agree with that
um but as it relates to that number that
number included a number of things
conquered 72 percent of Concord is
taxable the rest of it is non-taxable
because of non-profits State facilities
the next town up has 89 percent of its
land taxable so we have a significant
issue as it relates to property tax and
limiting what that can be raised
the other issue is the amount of land
that is available that is written in
current use or there was a lot of land
bought with Federal money in the 60s and
70s with Watershed money and limits
development so in this number includes a
number of things one land acquisition
to prepping the land
three this building would be electric
and also geothermal all those green
energy type things are significant
dollars these are things that the
community said they wanted it also
includes a full-size Auditorium to fit
every kid in there so in 900 seat
Auditorium under State funding you would
fund almost half that almost half of
that so that would be stuff that the
local has to decide do they reduce or do
they pick up that cost difference
so you also have price escalations so in
speaking with our architect they have a
project that was quoted bid has started
they are now putting the HVAC systems in
a year and a half after start 32 million
was the number it's 46 It's the final
number
cost instead of 550 are running 800 a
square foot
I'm in a way glad that things might
tamper down a little bit because it's
finding that right time but that is the
reason because these prices are coming
back significantly higher than we had
thought we had when we did this in 2017
with the initial visiting session the
school was 96 million dollars
much more reasonable but now it's okay I
hope that answers your question it is
just a crazy market and I think these
estimators are throwing numbers at it
and yes and but we are starting to see
some some cracks and I'm going to
appreciate the information thank you
very welcome
so uh a move also you had mentioned
about your the debt and I understand the
complexities as it relates to the
obligations for uh the debt that the
state committed to pay for bonds that
were done by local uh municipalities and
school districts obviously you can't
control that but it's really questioning
what if they got that money paid early
what would that mean I think moving to
the column where they borrowed the money
in the 1011 budget to fund their
obligations is really asking the key
questions is what is the call date on
that Bond and can it be paid off it may
not be worth it if it if the interest
rate's very low but I think asking what
the call date is and could they is there
a penalty for paying it for Concord we
took 30-year Bonds on our elementary
project the call date was 10 years we
hit it right at the right time we
refinanced and save 425 000 a year for
20 years by refinancing it
that may be something to look at too may
not be worth taking today's money and
paying that off that's part of the
things I look at too when you look down
the road what's the present value of
that money when you look down the road
it may not make sense for me some idea
might be in a combination of these bills
is you're going from an old program as I
said was unsustainable representative
Heath you had said that it was getting
higher and higher going up to 30 and
20-year commitments uh representative
you had mentioned you don't like that
but maybe going a little shorter because
you're going from one extreme of 20 30
years Dental it's paid off in two years
for a building that's going to be around
for 50 years
there's a lot of flexibilities that
municipalities and school districts have
as it relates to bonding and borrowing
but maybe amortize it over five years if
we took the 17 projects that you have
that were approved this year the state's
Commitment if everything was eligible as
uh as uh Amy Clark had mentioned not
every bit of that is eligible so even
though for Concord 176 million 40
percent is 70 million likely not every
bit of that is eligible but for the
eligible portion if that all got funded
up front and was amortized over five
years you could do your 50 million a
year and commit the funding and taking
care of 17 projects now
downside of that is what's available
after that so but could this be a test
thing to try and do a layered five-year
amortization because once you get the
five years you've knocked out a bunch
every year you're going to have debt
expire because that five is done then
the next five is done so it would be
stacked it's exactly what they do with
the New Hampshire retirement system as
it relates the benefits so it's not a 30
year and 20 year obligation but not
taking a 50-year beta building and
paying it off in two years but maybe
doing it in five and again you're
locking in at the rates and the
commitment of that day you're not paying
future obligations because you what
you've said is we're going to pay you x
amount over the five years states don't
pay any interest on that it's just money
that's encumbered to be for the future
years
so that's an idea there sorry
any questions
it's a good idea yeah I I I think it
might be able to help
um and then going speaking locally what
I see we're a little bit different
conquered uh as it relates to our school
board because it is an autonomous school
board and is the only one that has the
abilities of that in the state from my
understanding so it's a very powerful
position but even I'm sure it's no
different than the ones that go with
their pockets when they go to vote or
the nine board members I report to in
the end if there's no State commitment
they're not going to be able to commit
to moving forward it's the biggest thing
I hear from my board and I'm sure it's
the same thing with voters if they know
that state commitment is there to fund
it it makes it more palatable I know for
us if I get the state's portion I can
build this with no additional tax impact
to our residents
Concord since 2005 has earmarked five
percent of its general fund budget
or Debt Service it knows it's got seven
buildings it knows it's going they're
gonna Age and what happens is when we're
below that we put it into a trust fund
that the board oversees when we're above
it we draw down on it so we always
maintain five percent and the tax impact
is not significant so to give you an
idea
um if we don't have state aid and I
767 dollar tax increase in the first
year
for what for our budget on a 324 000
home okay
if I have building a
it's 411 the first year then when I
start applying the 10 and a half million
I have saved I can significantly
mitigate this I know this school is not
going to be 176 million that's why I'm
confident I did three elementary schools
10 years ago with no additional
tax impact and I feel can be done again
and I think there's a number of bills
here where there's a solution to be able
to fund schools and send a message to
local to your constituents back home
that the state's willing to commit and
make it sustainable
so
yeah thank you Mr chair uh let me start
by saying that I really want to commend
the concord's approach to taking that
you know five percent and saving it and
budgeting for very predictable building
expenses yes even in years when they
don't have projects frankly I wish more
communities would do that and I think at
some point the state should discuss ways
to uh encourage them to plan accordingly
because long range planning no building
jumps on you as a surprise those things
are there for decades
some boards choose to be responsible and
I appreciate that some boards choose to
wait and see and not spend money today
and then they get hit with a huge bill
in terms of the your ability to
refinance because you had a 10-year
option I'm glad that that gamble worked
out for you but you did have to pay a
higher interest rate when you offer the
bonds because that call option causes
investors to require a bit more you know
interest so every you know it's a good
strategy but I think the Bond Bank is
taking the no call option to cut costs
up front so they are much more
challenged in their abilities to
refinance
and um
oh look at that never mind I lost that
train of thought I'll differ right now
all right
thank you all right thank you
uh what I'd like to do is bundle the
next these three bills
we'll take one vote but you'll the clerk
will fill out three different
uh voting sheets so that I would look
for a motion to retain 332 541 and 546.
oh second uh
representative Heath and
a representative Petrie okay
if the clerk would call the roll
this would be thank you we are having a
motion to retain all three Bills
currently under consideration
representative Bean
myself yes representative Buco yes
representative Heath
representative Murray yes representative
Hawkins Phillips yes and chairman
emmeric yes emotions pass a to zero
again this will be recorded as three
separate motions for three separate
bills so they are all taken care of
thank you thank you
well
it's been a good morning I think I'm a
lot smarter than I was when I showed up
uh
I don't know when we'll reconvene but at
any time if you have ideas we're gonna
have to solve this one or at least make
an attempt
uh I've got to sleep on it a little bit
what what I gotta sleep a little bit off
right that would be helpful
any ideas just email us as a group yeah
okay
so this came up quite a bit last term
and we heard testimony from the treasure
that it's not really a feasible option
with the bond the bonds on the uh that
are issued for that debt
okay yes
committee with for how thank you
um
the three sponsors of these bills and a
couple of us to see if at least
combining things down into one bill
um
is that we were attaining all three
we're going to have to at some point
make decisions
um on this the elements of the bills
that differ from one another and is
there a way of having that discussion in
terms of what do we want to keep and
what should we not keep I really I
thank you
right
so it works just as well to maintain
wait until we actually have the money to
deal with it I think we have to know how
much money how big the stack of bucks
are
but
yeah
uh
yeah let's sleep on it because I I want
to go back and reread the bills now that
I understand what it
the program is and I will just remind
everyone that you may have touched on
this representative Murray you will get
a fourth
um
proposal if you will when you do get
House Bill one and two so the governor's
position on school building a will be in
there one way or another whether it's
you know along the lines of any of these
a different proposal or just leaving the
program as it is so that'll just be
something else to consider uh in all
likelihood whatever this committee's
policy the position on school building
it'll be House Bill one and two so these
bills will
you know we can revisit them over the
summer they may be uh
the point may be moved by then because
you may have had something in the budget
already passed and you'd it all the
bills later but at this point you're
keeping the subject matter Alive by
retaining them we'll deal with it in the
budget
more to follow
stay tuned yeah have a good afternoon
all